even the search engine duckduckgo which
you may use because they promised you
that they would not use algorithms
algorithms to suppress your speech or
track your searches online
has joined the herd duckduckgo's ceo is
promising that the search engine will
downrank sites that are quote associated
with russian disinformation associated
with okay
in other words saying things that by
administration doesn't like youtube has
just removed an episode of the full send
podcast featuring donald trump it got 5
million views in 24 hours
but they couldn't handle it
so they hit it blake masters is the ceo
of teal capital he's running for senate
in the state of arizona we're happy to
have him join us now blake masters
thanks so much for coming on so in the
name of protecting freedom we seem to be
eliminating it here have you noticed
this
i've noticed tucker a lot of people here
in arizona have noticed and it's just so
absurd i mean duckduckgo is supposed to
be the free speech search engine right
that's right it's entire point but now
they've decided to censor whatever they
say is disinformation and sorry but that
makes them no better than google you
know just another ideological tech
company that wants to censor and
manipulate i mean what a joke well it's
especially distressing because a lot of
us use duck go which is of course
inferior to google google has a great
product that's why it's so big and so
you know they've misused that power for
evil um so is there an option i mean
you're a tech guy is there some search
engine you can go to that doesn't have
its fingers secretly
on the facts feeding you propaganda
well we're running out of options i mean
i do recommend the brave browser uh and
the brave search engine now but you know
here's the thing i think we can
acknowledge that yeah propaganda exists
misinformation exists lies exist and
those are bad and remember tucker the
vast majority of democrats in this
country believe that russians hacked
voting machines in 2016 to elect trump i
mean that's just delusional of course
but what a propaganda coup that is the
biggest russian disinformation story uh
of our time and here's the thing you
don't fight that by becoming more like
russia right you don't stop that by
having sensors tell us what we're
allowed to think
well of course and by the way maybe i
missed it but i haven't seen really any
russian disinformation or russian news
force anything from russia or its agents
in this country in a very long time all
the misinformation propaganda i see
comes from the white house have you
noticed
there's an awful lot coming from the
white house and of course big tech's got
its hook into the white house right it's
hard to to know where the white house
stops and where big tech starts and
that's why we can't trust big tech to
police itself right you can't rely on
big tech to check big tech and you can't
just say well build your own
alternative right because these
companies when they get big and
successful they all succumb to the same
pressures and you mentioned that youtube
just yesterday they ripped off president
trump's interview with the nilk boys
like what is that this is a highly
successful interview with the the former
president of the united states like my
gosh and they just decided to censor it
and google tucker i will say google is
the worst offender google of course owns
youtube but google has the power to
swing a presidential election and for
all we know that's exactly what they did
in 2020 well i don't think there's any
question about that and to topple
governments around the world
blake masters from arizona running for
senate appreciate it thank you
thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else